[Applause]
it lasted just three days but this
week's Junior doctor strike was the most
disruptive industrial action in the NHS
yet with 175 000 appointments and
operations canceled
but yesterday's 4 billion pound
breakthrough for NHS staff like nurses
has left those representing doctors
feeling optimistic
positive that the the other unions of Mr
Buckley have been able to have talked I
do hope that we can work towards an
arrangement of course unions have had a
health care sectors have had varying
levels of real terms pay cuts so I hope
that he brings us something that will be
accessible to our members some argue the
government has been canny by first
picking off these striking workers most
popular with the public in nurses but
even with that proposed pay deal
questions remain because even if union
members vote for it it is not clear how
the government will pay for it to make
that happen something else has to give
it might be that there's cuts to
headcount it might be there's cuts to
other things like investment in Digital
Services it might mean that they have to
somehow squeeze out some further
efficiency savings at this stage we
don't know
teacher strikes are on pause as the
leaders of England's teaching unions are
now in intensive negotiations with the
government are you hoping for the test
though tonight they were tight-lipped
meanwhile the PCS Union have announced
passport workers will soon strike for
five weeks well I think it's looking
pretty bleak at the moment
um I think the common denominator for me
is the government you know we've seen
real progress made in Scotland across
all social sectors we've seen progress
in Wales we've seen progress for
firefighters with the English local
authorities but up until yesterday
anywhere where the Westminster
government makes a decision there's been
no progress at all
there's more misery for Holiday makers
on the horizon with the unite Union
announcing 10 days of industrial action
at Heathrow over Easter
some workers may now have landed a deal
but for others the journey is far from
over Joe Pike Sky News